des chefs d'état rail est caricaturé
ridiculiser avec en faire part a dit
bernard rancillac peint des personnages
marquants du 20e siècle
l'artiste français crocs depuis soixante
dix ans l'histoire avec un regard acerbe
c'est un rebelle c'est un homme
passionné qui a toujours pris position
qui est un qui est engagée à sa manière
c'est un peintre qui travaille à partir
de photographies ou à partir d'image
c'est à dire que si vous voulez c'est un
peintre qui a beaucoup réfléchi dans les
années 60 70 du siècle dernier au rôle
de la de la photographie dans les
magazines rancillac dit au fond nous ne
savons plus regarder le monde tel qu en
lui même nous ne regardons plus qu'avec
des photos qu'à travers des photos qui
peuplent nos mémoires ce qu'il préfère
c'est montrer la vie bernard rancillac
utilise la couleur vive pour attirer
l'oeil et faire réfléchir à l'actualité
maintenant il peint à l'acrylique c'est
à dire une toile qui est une peinture
qui est venu dans le commerce en danger
au milieu des années 60 qu'il a tout de
suite adopté parce qu'elle sèche très
vite c'est à dire que vous commencez une
toile le matin vous pouvez voir le soir
même ce que ça
ce que ça donne et quand vous peignez
l'actualité que vous payez à partir de
photos et que vous êtes un homme pressé
comme rancillac et bien évidemment saadé
ça a des avantages une quinzaine de
toiles retrace la carrière de bernard
rancillac l'exposition yvelinoise
complète la rétrospective proposée
actuellement par le musée de la poste à
l'espace niemeyer à paris